the
pennsylvania republican senate primary
uh we know that
it's it's kind of come down there there
are you know there's three or four
people that are in the race still but
it's really kind of come down to kathy
barnett
versus dr oz and kathy barnett sort of
exploded onto the scene
last week when she took dr oz to task
for his for his support of abortion in
the past
and uh she had a very powerful you know
some very powerful words from her own
experience um and why she's she's
pro-life
and now the
the
so-called conservatives who have become
dr oz shills for some reason
have set out especially over the last
couple of days
it has been an onslaught to try to
destroy this woman kathy barnett and
they're putting they're taking out of
context
clipped things and they're making
montages and putting it online they're
digging through her tweets is what
conservatives are doing
digging through tweets from like nine
years ago
to try to find offensive things to take
this person down
and but what they're actually finding
is that um they're really working
against themselves because as they dig
through our tweets what they find is
that oh back in 2014 she was pro-life
she was socially conservative
as opposed to dr oz who
back 10 years ago as we played on the
show a few weeks ago
10 years ago he was pushing puberty
blockers for trans kids so-called
quote-unquote trans kids
now what you understand about dr oz when
it comes to the gender
ideology issue in particular is
um he was
on the forefront
of pushing gender ideology on the kids i
mean this was a he did a segment his
first segment on it was 2010 2011.
so he didn't even he didn't jump on the
bandwagon
he was driving the bandwagon
to push puberty blockers
and gender confusion and gender
transition onto kids now that's all we
need to know about him actually that's
that's enough that should disqualify him
forever and more than that anybody in
the on the right who's shilling for him
is also as far as i'm concerned
disqualified forever from having any
kind of credibility
um someone who was
pushing gender transition onto kids no
period
like i don't care what else you've done
in your
life don't care if outside of that
you've been a a war hero i don't care
about i don't care what else you've done
you do that you're disqualified
that's happened with dr oz though it's
just this is just one in a in a parade
of
uh of leftist radicalism that we've seen
from him he's pro-abortion while kathy
barnett even six seven eight years ago
was speaking out
to protect the unborn six seven eight
years ago dr oz was pro-abortion two
years ago he was pro-abortion
pro-gun control
you know he was talking about um
uh
systemic racism and then only this is
less than two years ago about a year and
a half ago
this was a segment on dr oz's show
about the jacob blake case let's watch
this here
shot seven times in the back
family of jacob blake speaks out he was
trying to kill myself
his devastating injuries hurts to
breathe rehearsal sleep do they think
he'll be able to walk again then behind
the horrifying death of daniel prune
and mental health crisis gone terribly
wrong i called for help and that was the
help they gave them they don't even
treat animals like that next to us
this was not 20 years ago this was in
2020
and he was pushing the jacob blake false
narrative
and i don't hear any excuses about oh we
didn't know at the time
um if
if you're an honest and rational person
you knew immediately that the narrative
over jacob blake was false i knew
immediately first time i saw the video
before we even knew all the other
details i mean i didn't know initially
that jacob blake for example you know
allegedly broke into this woman's house
and uh and raped her and then uh stole
her credit cards in her car and all that
and then he showed back up at her house
and she called the cops and that's what
precipitated all this like i didn't know
that backstory i wasn't surprised by it
when i did learn it but just watching
the video it was clear enough
that he was fighting with the cops he
was at least trying to steal a car he
was reaching into a car he had a knife i
mean you could see all that in the video
and this is why the police officer in
that case was not charged with any crime
because um
because
he didn't do anything wrong
jacob blake was a thousand percent in
the wrong so this was dr oz back in 2020
less than two years ago pushing uh you
know
the radical blm agenda and a false
anti-police narrative coming to the
defense of jacob blake who is an utter
total woman abusing predator scumbag
and now there are
conservatives who want who want him to
be in the senate
as a
republican like this guy he has
zero record
of anything remotely conservative
his entire record his entire public
career has been spent pushing leftism
in its most radical forms
and he doesn't even live in pennsylvania
he's a turkish citizen
so a turkish citizen and new jersey
resident
leftist is running for the senate as a
republican in pennsylvania
and he's being uh he's being pushed and
promoted by
very prominent people on the right to
include president you know president
trump
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
give it a thumbs up and share it with
all your friends